- 「量子情報と計算の理解」へようこそ。
私の名前はJohn Watrousだ。IBM Quantum Educationの
テクニカルディレクターを務めている。
このシリーズの目的は、量子情報と計算について
しっかりとした理解を提供することだ。つまり、技術的な詳細に
踏み込んで、量子情報を見て、量子
コンピューティングが実際どう動くのか、何ができて何ができないのかを理解することだ。
まだこのシリーズの
概要動画を見ていないなら、ぜひチェックしてほしい。
その動画では、このシリーズに推奨される
事前準備の種類についての情報と、
扱うトピックの概要が見つかる。
また、Qiskitテキストブックも
ぜひチェックしてほしい。このシリーズと同じ
内容を文書形式でカバーしている。
さらに、インタラクティブなコンポーネントや
ハードウェアおよびソフトウェアへのインターフェースも含まれており、
理解を深めるのに役立つよう設計されている。
量子情報と計算について。概要動画とQiskitテキストブックへの
リンクは説明欄に載っている。
これはシリーズのユニット1の
レッスン1だ。
ユニット1では量子情報の
基礎を扱う。このユニットの最初のレッスンでは、
量子情報がどう機能するかに焦点を当てる。
単一システムにおける場合、つまり
量子情報を保存する物理的なシステムか
何らかのデバイスが1つだけある場合だ。
そして、その1つのシステムまたはデバイスが
単独でどう機能するかを考察する。
次のレッスンでは、複数のシステムがある場合に
量子情報がどう機能するかを議論する。それによって
複数のqubitを使う量子アルゴリズムなどの
興味深く重要な概念を
記述できるようになる。また、量子情報を処理して
互いにやり取りする複数の個人が関与する
量子プロトコルも扱う。
しかしこれらの議論に入る前に、
比較的シンプルな単一システムを単独で扱う設定から始めるのが理にかなっている。
シンプルに始めるのが良いということもあるが、
これから見ていくように、量子情報がどう機能するかの説明が
単独の単一システムにおける場合、
量子情報がどう機能するかの説明へと
非常に自然かつ論理的につながっていくからだ。
複数のシステムの場合においても。
レッスンの簡単な概要を示す。
まず古典情報について
議論するところから始める。
このレッスンの目的は古典情報がどう機能するかを
説明することではなく、
量子情報がどう機能するかを説明することだ。
しかし量子情報がどう機能するかを
説明するには、古典情報から始めて
それを身近な参照点として使うことが非常に役立つ。
量子情報を議論する際に。
数学的なレベルでは、量子と古典の情報は
いくつかの重要な違いはあるものの、
実はかなり似た記述を持っている。
実際、量子情報は
古典情報とまったく別物というわけではない。
古典情報の
拡張なんだ。
実のところ、少なくとも私の見解では、
古典情報を理解せずに
量子情報を本当に理解することはできない。
だから古典情報から始めることは
理にかなっている。
この内容は一部の視聴者には
馴染みのあるものだろうが、たとえ知っていても
スキップすることはお勧めしない。
量子情報の理解に最も関連する
古典情報の側面を強調するとともに、
このパートではDirac記法を導入する。
これはシリーズを通じて
ベクトルと行列を記述するために
使う標準的な方法だ。
実はDirac記法は
量子情報に特有のものではない。
古典情報の文脈でも、またベクトルと行列が
登場する他の多くの場面でも
同様に使える。
次に量子情報へと進む。具体的には、
ベクトルとしての量子状態の表現について
議論する。
標準基底測定と呼ばれるシンプルな測定の種類と、
量子システムにおける離散時間変化を記述する
ユニタリ操作についても扱う。
ここでも、単一システムの
設定における話だ。
レッスン本体を始める前に、
量子情報の記述には実際2種類あることを
明確にしておくと役立つだろう。
簡略化された記述と一般的な記述だ。
簡略化された記述はこのレッスンで
焦点を当てる内容だ。
そしてこの最初のユニット全体を通じて扱う。
一般的な記述は後のユニット、
具体的にはシリーズの第3ユニットで扱われる。
簡略化された記述はその名の通り
よりシンプルで、通常は
最初に学ばれる。
簡略化された記述では、すでに示唆したように、
量子状態はベクトルで表され、
操作はユニタリ行列で表される。
量子情報のこの記述は、
例えばほとんどの量子アルゴリズムの
理解には十分だ。
だから過度に単純化されているわけではなく、
本物なんだ。
しかし、進んでいくにつれて
わかるように、いくつかの制限もある。
例えば、量子システムへのノイズの影響を
モデル化したい場合、
この記述では不十分であることがわかる。
一方、一般的な記述はより汎用的で、
数学的な意味でより強力だ。
この記述では、量子状態は
密度行列と呼ばれる特殊なクラスの行列で表される。
そして、ノイズなどを含む、
より一般的なクラスの測定や操作を
記述できる。
これは簡略化された記述と完全に
整合していて、実際、簡略化された記述は
一般的な記述の特殊ケースとして
捉えることができる。また、古典的な情報も
特殊ケースとして含まれている。
その仕組みも本当に美しい。
だから、この一般的な記述についても
ぜひ学んでほしい。
適切なタイミングでね。ただ、簡略化された記述の方が
より自然な出発点なので、まずそこから始める。
まず古典的な情報について話していく。
量子情報に最も関連する
古典的な情報の側面に
注目しながら、それが数学的に
どう記述されるかを見ていく。
情報を格納する何らかの物理システムや
デバイスがあると想像してほしい。
このシステムにXという名前をつけるが、
この名前に特別な意味はない。
別の名前でも構わないが、
名前を決めるということで、
このシステムをXと呼ぶことにする。
Xについて一つ前提を置く。
それは、Xがある瞬間に取りうる
古典的な状態の有限集合が存在するということだ。
ここで古典的な状態というのは、
曖昧さなく認識・記述できる
システムの配置を意味する。
不確実性や誤りは一切ない。
これは直感的に考えられるものだ。
数学的なレベルでは、
古典的な状態の集合を単純に定義する。
扱っているデバイスを最もうまく記述できる
方法で、好きなように選べばいい。
この古典的な状態の集合にsigmaという名前をつける。
そして改めて強調しておくが、
sigmaは有限集合だと仮定している。
このシステムXの古典的な状態の集合は、
自然数の集合のように
無限に大きくはない。
有限だ。それがここで置いている前提だ。
例えば、Xがビットである場合、
古典的な状態の集合は
ゼロと一の2つの要素を含む集合になる。
この集合を二値アルファベットと
呼ぶこともある。
もう一つの例は、Xが普通の6面サイコロの場合で、
その場合、古典的な状態は
1から6の数字になる。
もちろん、ここでは抽象化の話をしている。
実際の6面サイコロには、
正確な位置や向きなど、
様々な属性があるかもしれない。
温度なども含めてね。でも、6面サイコロについて
話す際に最も一般的に関連する情報という観点では、
古典的な状態は、上を向いているサイコロの面の
点の数で示される1から6の数字だ。
Xがよくある家庭用扇風機のスイッチであれば、
古典的な状態は
強、中、弱、オフという
設定になるだろう。
これらは単なる例だ。これら以外の古典的な状態の集合を
持つシステムも考えられるが、
古典的な状態という概念が
馴染みのあるものであり、
シンプルで直感的に理解できるものだと
伝わっていれば幸いだ。
数学的に言えば、古典的な状態の集合は
単なる有限集合であり、
もちろん空でない必要もある。
システムが取りうる古典的な状態が
少なくとも一つは必要で、
少なくとも2つの古典的な状態が
あって初めて、情報を格納するために
役立つシステムになれる。
さて、状況によってはXが
特定の状態にあることが分かっている場合もあるが、
多くの状況では、
情報処理の場面において、
ある瞬間のシステムの古典的な状態に
不確実性がある場合がある。
その場合、各古典的な状態に
ある確率が対応している。
例えば、Xがビットの場合、
Xが古典的な状態ゼロにある確率が
4分の3で、状態1にある確率が
4分の1、という場合が考えられる。
これを確率的状態と呼ぶ。
この確率的状態は、ここに示したように
表現できる。
単純に、異なる古典的な状態に対する
確率が何かを示すだけだ。
この確率的状態をより簡潔に表現するには
ベクトルを使う。具体的には、
ここに示した表現が
列ベクトルであり、このベクトルが
2つの古典的な状態の確率を示している。
より具体的には、最初の要素が
Xが状態ゼロにある確率を示し、
2番目の要素が
システムが状態1にある確率を示している。
これは二値アルファベットを順序付ける
自然な方法だ。
少なくとも、私たちが訓練されている方法はそうだ。
ゼロが最初、一が2番目。
今後は、このようなベクトルを示すために
確率ベクトルという用語を使う。
具体的には、すべての要素が
非負の実数であり、要素の合計が
1に等しいベクトルだ。
だから、これらの要素を
確率として考えるのは理にかなっている。
この例では、話しているシステムの
古典的な状態がちょうど2つだから、
要素もちょうど2つだ。
でも一般的には、要素の数はいくつでもあり得る。
ただし、各古典的な状態に対して
1つの要素があるという理解のもとでだ。
話しているどんなシステムでも
そうだ。
古典的な情報、確率ベクトルなどの話は
すぐ後でも続けるが、まず、
ベクトルを記述するための記法を
紹介しておくととても便利だ。
それがDirac記法として知られている記法だ。
実は、これはDirac記法の
第一部にすぎない。
Dirac記法には他にも
いくつかの側面があって、
それはこのレッスンの少し後で見ていく。
この記法は量子情報を記述する方法の
中心となるものだから、
どう機能するかを理解することが不可欠だ。
でも幸いなことに、非常にシンプルで、
量子情報とは特に関係がない。
だから今は、
馴染みのある古典的な情報の文脈で
紹介できる。
以前と同じように、あるシステムの
古典的な状態の集合sigmaがあると仮定して、
さらに
これらの古典的な状態に順序があると
仮定しよう。ちょうど二進アルファベットの
順序を参照するように。
前の例でそうしたように。
別の言い方をすれば、sigmaの要素が
整数と対応付けられているということだ。
1からsigmaに含まれる要素の数まで。
sigmaの両側にバーが2つある
この記法がそれを意味している。
つまり、集合sigmaの
要素の数だ。
つまり、第一の状態、第二の状態、
といった具合にある。
選ぶ特定の順序や
対応関係は実際にはあまり重要じゃない。
本当に重要なのは、
順序を持ってそれを守ることだ。
これから扱う多くの古典的な状態集合には、
二進アルファベットのように
標準的な順序がある。
標準的な順序がなければ、
自分で選べばいい。
でも何であれ、
それを守るという理解のもとで進む。
では、ここで
紹介する記法だ。
集合sigmaからの古典的な状態aの
任意の選択に対して、
ここに書いているものをket aと読む。
これはaに対応する要素に1があり、
他のすべての要素に0がある
列ベクトルを意味する。
例えば、二進アルファベットに
戻ってみよう。これはご想像の通り、
非常に重要な例だ。
これから何度も戻ってくることになる。
そうすると、ket zeroとket oneは
ここに定義されているベクトルだ。
ket zeroは、古典的な状態zeroに
対応する要素、つまり第一要素に
1があるベクトルだ。
他のすべての要素には0があり、
この場合、他の要素は
1つだけだ。
同様に、ket oneは
ここにあるベクトルで、1に
対応する要素に1がある。
それは第二要素で、他のすべての要素には0がある。
やはり、それは1つだけだ。
別の例を見てみよう。この例では、
トランプの4つのスートに対応する
古典的な状態集合sigmaがある。
クラブ、ダイヤ、ハート、スペードだ。
この場合、これらのスートの
普遍的に合意された順序は
実際には存在しない。
多くのカードゲームでは順序が全くない。
ただ4つの異なるスートがあるだけで
それだけが重要だ。そして、これらのスートを
異なる方法で順序付けするカードゲームもあるが、
それは特に重要じゃない。
ここで見ているような
順序を選べばいい。
これは英語で書かれた4つのスートの名前に
従ったアルファベット順だ。
この特定の順序を選んだと仮定すると、
4つのベクトルを定義する：
ket clubs、ket diamonds、ket hearts、ket spades。
ここで見ているように、これらのベクトルは
上に見える一般的な記述に対応している。
これら4つのスートに対して
この特定の順序を選んだということを
踏まえてだ。
選ぶ任意の古典的な状態集合に対して
同じことができる。
古典的な状態集合は常に
有限かつ空でない集合を意味することを
念頭に置きながら。
この形のベクトルは標準基底ベクトルと呼ばれ、
すべてのベクトルが
標準基底ベクトルの線形結合として
一意の方法で表せるというのは、
ベクトルに関する非常に基本的な事実だ。
例えば、少し前の例に戻ると、
見た確率ベクトルは次のように表せる。
ここで見ているように。
これは基本的にベクトルを表現する
別の方法に過ぎない。
これは今後いくつかの理由から
非常に便利になる。
この表記法を手に入れたところで、古典的情報と確率的状態、
特にその議論に戻ろう。
系が何らかの確率的状態にあるとき、
それを測定したら何が起きるかを考えてみよう。
古典的な状況で何かを測定したり、
測定という行為を行うことは、
普通はあまり言わないかもしれないが、この言葉は意味をなす。
本質的に、この文脈で系Xを測定すると言うとき、
それは単にそれを見て、どんな状態にあるかを認識するということだ。
もちろん、系を見ても確率的状態は見えない。
見えるのは古典的状態だ。
そして見えるその特定の古典的状態は、
確率に従ってランダムに選ばれると
想像できるものだ。
ここで、測定した瞬間に見える古典的状態が
何らかの形でランダムに選ばれるという考えに、
哲学的な観点から異論があるかもしれない。
測定した瞬間、つまり系を見た瞬間、
系はずっとある特定の
古典的状態にあったはずだ、という反論だ。
そしてただ偶然に
その状態が何であったかを知ったに過ぎない、とも言えるが、
扱っている数学的な
枠組みで考えるためには、
このように考えてもよく、
そうすることで少し後に
量子情報との類比を引き出せる。
見える古典的状態が、集合シグマの中の
任意の状態でありうる古典的状態aだと仮定しよう。
これは一般に、少なくとも我々の観点からは、
Xの確率的状態を変える。
Xの古典的状態が何かを
今は分かっているので、
確率はもはや意味を持たない。
それはaであり、
これについてはもはや
不確かさはない。
だから今では、
系が状態aにある確率は1だと言える。
それを見て古典的状態がaだと分かったからで、
Xの新しい確率的状態は1だ。
古典的状態aにある確率が
1に等しい状態だ。
そしてその確率的状態は
確率ベクトルのket aで表される。
古典的状態aに対応するエントリに1があり、
他のすべてのエントリには0がある。
例えば、再びXがbitである状況を考え、
以前と同じ確率的状態を持つとすると、
Xを測定すると、
遷移が起きると想像できる。
4分の3の確率で古典的状態0が見え、
測定によってket 0へ遷移し、
それが確率的状態になる。
そして4分の1の確率でket 1へ遷移する。
これは、実際の物理的な遷移ではなく、
知識の遷移として考えることもできる。
でもこのレッスンで重要なのは、
数学がどう機能するかを認識することだ。
実はかなり自明なことだが、この自明さを認識することで、
量子の状況での類似した記述が
少し謎めいて見えなくなるかもしれない。
最後の補足として、我々が測定したとき、
Xの古典的状態が何だったかたまたま見ていなかった
別の人にとっては、
確率的状態は、
我々が測定したことの結果として
自然には変わらない。
それでいい。異なる個人が
特定の系について異なる知識を持ち、
それに応じて
異なる確率的状態を選べる。
その系の知識を
表すために。
この古典的情報の議論の最後の部分では、
系に対して実行できる古典的な操作について話す。
決定論的な操作から始めよう。
系に操作を実行すると、その結果として状態は一般に変化する。
この文脈で決定論的という言葉が意味するのは、
操作を実行した結果が、
系がどんな古典的
状態にあったかに完全に依存するということだ。
操作が実行される前の状態に。
言い換えれば、
決定論的な操作が実行されるとき、
偶然の要素はなく、ランダム性も
不確かさも関与しない。
数学的には、決定論的な操作は
関数によって記述される。
ここに示す形のすべての関数f、
つまり関数の入力と出力の両方が
我々の古典的状態の集合シグマの
要素に対応するものは、決定論的な操作を記述する。
古典的状態aは、
状態aの各選択に対して、
f(a)という状態に変換される。
この形のすべての関数fに対して、
ここに示すこの条件を満たす一意な行列Mが
常に存在する。
それはMをベクトルket aに掛けることで
ベクトルket f(a)が得られる、ということだ。
そしてそれはすべての
古典的状態aの選択に対して成り立つ。
選んだこの形の関数fを使って、
Mの明示的な記述を書き下すのは
それほど難しくない。
各列には常にちょうど1つの1があり、
他のすべてのエントリは0に等しい。
そして公式はこうだ。Mのb, aエントリはbがf(a)に等しい場合に1に等しい。
それ以外は0に等しく、
これはbに対応する行と
aに対応する列の
Mのエントリを意味する。
すぐにいくつかの例を見ていくが、なぜこの公式が成り立つのかも分かるはずだ。
なぜ関数をこのような行列で表したいのか、今はまだ明確じゃないかもしれない。
でも、そうする意味はちゃんとある。その理由の一つ、そしておそらく最大の理由は、システムが確率的な状態にある場合、
そのシステムに対して決定論的な操作を行うと、結果として得られる確率的な状態は
行列とベクトルの積によって求められるということだ。つまり、システムが確率的な状態にある場合、
その状態がある確率ベクトルvで表されていて、Mで記述される決定論的な操作を
そのシステムに対して行うと、結果の確率的な状態はMにvを掛けたものになる。
ちなみにここで、このような小さな縦棒の付いた矢印は、数学においてある一つのものが別のものにどのように対応するかを示す
一般的な記法だ。普通の矢印を使うこともできるが、こちらが慣例的で
認識しやすく、多くの意味を持ちうる普通の矢印よりも少し具体的かもしれない。
では、例を一つ、というか実際にはいくつかの例を見てみよう。
古典状態集合sigmaを再び二進アルファベットとした場合に何が起こるかを考えてみよう。
これを古典状態集合とした場合、これまで議論してきた形の関数はそれほど多くない。より正確に言えば、この形の関数はちょうど四つだけだ。
ここでは、その四つの関数をいわゆる値の表で表している。
最初の表は最初の関数を表していて、それをf1と名付けた。
左側の可能な各入力に対して、右側に対応する出力を並べているので、f1のゼロはゼロに等しく、
f1の一も、また、ゼロに等しい。つまりf1は定数ゼロ関数だ。
常にゼロという値を取る。
二番目の関数f2は恒等関数だ。
二番目の表から分かるように、出力は常に入力と等しい。
三番目の関数f3は三番目の表で表されている。
f3のゼロは一に等しく、f3の一はゼロに等しい。
この関数はnot関数、あるいは論理否定としてよく知られている。
ゼロを一に、一をゼロにひっくり返すことから、ビットフリップと呼ぶこともある。
最後の関数f4は、最初の関数と同様に定数関数だが、こちらは定数一関数だ。
常に一という値を取るからだ。
そして、それが二進アルファベットからそれ自身への関数がちょうど四つしかない理由だ。
ここに、これら四つの関数に対応する四つの行列を示す。これらは前述の公式、
ここで見えているこの公式によって記述されている。興味があれば、動画を一時停止して確認してみるといい。
行列においてインデックスの順序は常に行が先で列が後だということを覚えておいてほしい。
つまり、b、aのエントリはb行a列、すなわち古典状態bに対応する行と
古典状態aに対応する列のことだ。
例えば、最初の関数を見ると、f1のゼロはゼロに等しく、
対応して、M1のゼロ、ゼロエントリは一に等しい。
一方、ここにあるように一、ゼロエントリはゼロに等しい。そして入力が一の場合についても同様のことができる。
他の三つの関数についても同様だ。
また、前述の公式が正しいことも確認できる。様々な可能性を一つ一つ確かめていけばいい。
実際、行列の掛け算がどのように機能するかを考えると、これは直感的に分かる。
このような標準基底ベクトルに行列を掛けると、入力を
古典状態に対応する行列のどれかの列の上から落とし込んでいると想像できる。
ket内の古典状態に対応する列に入力を入れると、出力として得られるのはその列そのものが確率ベクトルとして返ってくるだけだ。
例えば、M3にket ゼロを掛けると、ゼロ、一が得られる。
確率ベクトルとして、これはket 一だ。
M3にket 一を掛けると、一、ゼロが得られる。これはket ゼロだ。同様に続く。
確率的な状態に対する操作についてはすぐに詳しく議論するが、その前にDirac記法の二番目の部分を紹介しよう。
これは操作について話し、それを行列Cとして考えるのに役立つし、今後も標準的なツールとして
使い続けるものだ。設定は以前と同じだ。
作業している古典状態集合sigmaがあり、それらの古典状態に何らかの順序付けがあると仮定する。
そして、ここで見えるこのものを書く。今度は角括弧付きの縦棒が右ではなく左にあり、aに対応するエントリに一を持つ行ベクトルを意味する。
他のすべての古典状態に対応する他のすべてのエントリはゼロだ。
つまり、このものとket aの違いは、これが行ベクトルでket aが列ベクトルだという点だ。
それ以外の場合、ベクトルは
同様の方法で定義される。
これをbra aと読む。面白い名前かどうかわからないが、
braとketという名前の意味は
bracketという単語の前半と後半だ。
これについてはすぐにまた触れる。
でもまず、非常に簡単な
例を見てみよう。
2値アルファベットの場合、bra zeroは
ket aに類似したこの行ベクトルだ。
ただし列ベクトルではなく行ベクトルで、
bra oneはこのベクトルだ。
一般的に、行ベクトルを列ベクトルに
掛けると、これらを行列として考えると
1行または1列しかない行列になり、
1×1行列になる。これはスカラーと考えられる。
ちなみに、これらの星印は
任意の数を表していると考えてほしい。
特に、行ベクトルbra aを
列ベクトルket bに掛けると、
2つの場合が起こりうる。
1つはaとbが等しい場合、つまり同じ古典的な状態で、
その場合は1が揃い
積は1になる。あるいは
aとbが異なる場合もある。
その場合、1が揃わないので
積はゼロになる。
これらの観察を表す
シンプルな方法がこれだ。
整理のため、この積を中央に棒を1本だけ入れた
この形で書くが、意味はまったく同じだ。
これでbraとketが合わさってbracketを形成するのが
わかる。これは内積とも呼ばれ、
レッスン3で
改めて詳しく扱う
重要な概念だ。
一方、列ベクトルに行ベクトルを掛けると、
ここで見てわかるように行列が得られる。
例えば、再び2値アルファベットに戻ると、
ket zeroにbra zeroを掛けると、
この行列が得られる。他の組み合わせも
見ていこう。
ket zero × bra oneはこの行列で、
1がこの位置に移動している。
ket one、bra zeroはこうなり、
ket one、bra oneはこうだ。
わかるのは、行列の中に1がただ1つあり、
それ以外はすべてゼロで、その1の位置は
braとketで選んだ
古典的な状態によって決まる。
より正確には、これは一般的に成り立つが、
古典的な状態集合の任意の選択に対して、
ket aにbra bを掛けて得られる行列は
a, bの位置が1で、
それ以外がすべてゼロの行列だ。
Dirac記法の前半と後半の両方が揃ったので、
演算を行列と結びつける便利なツールが手に入った。
では、決定論的演算に
簡単に戻って、レッスンの少し前に
この形の関数fに対して、
各古典的な状態aをf(a)に変換する
決定論的演算があると述べたことを思い出してほしい。
そして、このような任意の関数に対して、
常にこのように作用する一意の
行列Mが存在すると言った。
標準基底状態に対してだ。
Dirac記法を使うと、ここで見えるように
この行列を非常に簡単に表現できる。
また、Dirac記法の枠組みの中だけで
行列を完全に扱うことが
できる場合もある。
数字で埋められた長方形、つまりベクトルや行列に
明示的に変換することなく扱える。
この場合、必要な公式が正しいことを
MをKet aに掛けることで確認できる。
Mの式をこのように代入して、
括弧を取り除き、bra bとket aを
このようにくっつける。
行列の掛け算は線形だからで、
この場合は第1引数について線形で、
結合的なので括弧を取り除ける。
そして、bのすべての可能な選択で
和を取る際に、固定されたaについて話していることを思い出すと、
このbracketはbがaと等しくない場合は
常にゼロになるので、
和への寄与はなく、
bがaと等しい場合、bracketは1になり、
この1つの項だけが残る。
これが求めていた公式で、関数を行列として
表す非常にきれいでシンプルな方法が得られた。
決定論的演算に加えて、
系の古典的な状態に対してランダム性や
不確実性をもたらす演算もある。
確率的演算という用語は、このような演算を指す。
正確に言うと、確率的演算と言う場合、
ランダム性をもたらす可能性のある演算を指す。
つまり、決定論的演算は実際には
確率的演算の特殊なケースで、
たまたま
ランダム性をもたらさないだけだ。
ランダム性が導入される
簡単な例を見てみよう。
これは1ビットに対する演算だ。動作としては、ビットの古典的な
状態がゼロなら
何も起こらない。ビットはゼロのままだが、
ビットの古典的な状態が1の場合、演算はビットをゼロに反転させる。
確率1/2で起こる。
この操作に特別な名前はない、
少なくとも私が知る限りは。
これは単なる例だが、
ビットに対してこの操作を行うことを想像できる。
決定論的操作と同様に、確率的操作も
行列で表現でき、確率的状態への作用は
以前と同じく行列とベクトルの積で与えられる。
今回は、行列の各列にちょうど一つの1があって
それ以外はゼロ、というわけではない。
確率的操作は
より一般的には確率行列で表される。
確率行列とは、全成分が
非負の実数で、各列の成分の和が
1になる行列だ。
これは、確率行列の各列が
確率ベクトルを形成する、と言うことと等価だ。
行列が標準基底ベクトルに作用することを考えると、
これは自然に納得できる。
任意の古典状態を考えて、
その状態をその古典状態に対応する列の
行列の上部に入れると想像する。
するとその列が、確率ベクトルとして
出力される確率的状態を教えてくれる。
例えば、この例における確率的操作は
ここに示すこの行列で記述される。
古典状態ゼロにこの操作を行うと、
得られる確率的状態は第一列で与えられる。
それはつまり、古典状態ゼロ、言い換えれば
確率1でゼロが出る確率的状態だ。
代わりに古典状態1にこの操作を行うと、
実質的にビットをランダム化することになり、
対応してここに示すこの確率ベクトルを得る。
各取りうる状態の確率が
1/2に等しいベクトルだ。
一般に、任意の確率的状態にこの操作を行うと、
その効果は本質的に二つの列の
加重平均になる。
なぜなら、それが行列とベクトルの積の
仕組みだからだ。
線形なので、二つの取りうる結果を
それぞれ平均するだけだ。
確率的操作をこのように考えると、
それらがランダム性を導入あるいは注入する
可能性があると考えるのは自然だ。
各列を一つずつ読めば、
各古典状態に対してどのようなランダム性が
導入されるかがわかる。
確率的操作については少し別の見方もできる。
それは、決定論的操作のランダムな選択だという見方だ。
例えばこの例では、この操作は
公平なコインを投げることと等価だと考えられる。
そして、定数ゼロ関数か恒等関数のどちらかを
各々確率1/2で実行する。
それはここに示す式で
反映されていることがわかる。
これは任意の確率的操作に対して
常に可能であり、かなり直感的だ。
何らかのプロセスの一部としてランダムな選択を行う場合、
それらのランダムな選択を事前に行うことを
想像できる。
そしてその選択を
決定論的操作の集合にハードコードする。
確率的操作をこのように考えることは
非常に役立つことがあり、数レッスン先で
この例を見ることになる。
このレッスンの古典情報について
最後に言うべきことは、確率的操作の合成に関するもので、
それは単に一つずつ順番に実行することを意味する。
Xという名前のシステムがあり、
M1からMnはX上の確率的操作を表す
確率行列だとする。
まず確率ベクトルvがあり、それはある時点での
Xの確率的状態を表すとする。
そして最初に適用する。
Xへの最初の確率的操作は行列M1で表される。
次に二番目の確率的操作を適用する。
それは行列M2で表される。
そうすると、最初の操作だけを適用した後の
確率ベクトルはM1×vだ。
次に二番目の操作を適用すると、
結果の確率ベクトルは、得られたベクトルに
M2を掛けたものになる。
M1を適用した後のベクトルに。つまりこうなる。
行列の積は結合的な操作であり、
括弧をどこに置いても関係ない。
なので、このように括弧を
置いても同じだ。
非常に単純だが、同時に興味深い。
なぜなら、最初にM1を適用する操作は
次にM2を適用して、
単一の操作として考えられることが明らかになるからだ。
言い換えれば、第一と第二の確率的操作を
合成して得られる確率的操作は、
行列の積M2×M1で表される。
そしてそれは、どの確率的状態から
始めても同じ操作だ。
この合成された操作を考えたり記述したりするために、
確率ベクトルvについて何も知る必要はない。
ここでの順序は左にM2、右にM1であることに
注目してほしい。右の行列M1が
ベクトルvに掛けられる一方、M2は
M1を掛けた後に得られるベクトルに
掛けられるからだ。
つまり、ある意味で順序が
逆になるということを常に念頭に置かなければならない。
最初に実行される演算は
右側にあるもので、最後に、つまりこの場合は2番目に実行される演算は
左側にある。
2番目の演算で止まらず、最初から最後、
つまりMnまでの順番で
すべてを適用するなら、
これらすべての演算の
合成は、ここに見えているこの積で
表される。
そして、前とまったく同じ理由で、
順序が再び逆になっているのが
わかるはずだ。
要するに、確率的演算の合成は、
それらを表す確率行列の積で
表される。
積の中での行列の
この順序に注意してほしい。
このように確率行列の積を取ると、
必ず確率行列が得られる。
このことを表すのに、
確率行列は乗法に関して
閉じていると言うことがある。
これを直感的に理解するには、
集合が閉じているので、確率行列の集合から
外に出ることはできないと
考えればいい。
この積の中での行列の順序に
話を戻すと、その順序が
本当に重要だということに注意が必要だ。
行列の乗法は可換じゃない。積の中で
行列の順序を変えると、
結果が変わる可能性がある。
これを確認するのに、
決定論的演算より
遠くを見る必要はない。
ここに簡単な例がある。
どちらも決定論的演算を表す
2つの確率行列で、順序が重要だ。
M1は定数ゼロ関数を表す。
先ほどの例と同様に、これらの2つの演算は
ビット上のものだと想定している。
M2はNOT演算、
つまりビット反転を
表している。
M1を先に実行してから
M2を実行すると、結果はここにあるこの行列で、
定数1関数を表す。
ビットをゼロに設定してから
反転させるのは、そのビットを
1に設定するのと同じことだ。
一方、M2を先に実行してから
M1を実行すると、ここに示す結果になる。
これは理にかなっている。ビットを反転させてから
ゼロに設定すると、
単にゼロに設定するのと同じことだからだ。
反転させたことは関係なかった。明らかに、
この2つの行列は同じじゃない。
だから、非常に
順序が重要だということを示す
シンプルな例がある。もちろん、これはまったく
驚くべきことじゃない。
演算が実行される順序が重要だということは、
少なくとも重要になりうることは、
みんな知っている。
例えば、マッチに火をつけてから
吹きかけると、最初にマッチに
吹きかけるのとは
まったく違う結果になる。
ここまで古典情報について
かなり話してきた。
いよいよ量子情報について
議論する時が来た。
数学的に言えば、量子情報は
いくつかの重要な違いはあるものの、
古典情報と非常に似た方法で
機能することがわかる。
最初の重要な違いは
最初のところにある。状態、この場合は
システムの量子状態をどう定義するかだ。
そして、この量子状態をどう定義するかという
1つの選択が、量子情報の
動作方法を大きく
決定するという意味がある。
測定と演算の働き方も定義する。
次のレッスンでは、量子情報が
単一システムだけでなく
複数のシステムに対して
どのように機能するかを議論する。
しかし、孤立した単一システムの
量子状態の概念が
確立されれば、これらは
かなり自然に導かれる。
定義を示そう。システムの量子状態は、
そのインデックスが
そのシステムの古典状態と
対応付けられた列ベクトルで
表される。
つまり、ここで話しているシステムは
古典情報について話したときと
同様に、何らかの古典状態の集合を
持つと仮定している。
確率状態と同様に。量子状態ベクトルの
成分は、確率的な場合の
成分が非負の実数であるのとは対照的に、
複素数だ。
そして今回は、成分の絶対値の2乗の和が
1に等しくなければならない。
これは確率的な場合の和が1に等しいのとは
対照的だ。
確率的な場合はそうなっている。
量子状態ベクトルに現れる複素数は
振幅と呼ばれることがあり、
確率と似た役割を果たす。
しかし、確率じゃないし、
同じ解釈もできない。
量子状態がなぜこのように定義されるべきかについて
納得できる理由を示すことはできない。
ただ、物理学者たちが
この定義が物理的に
妥当であり、量子力学的システムを
記述・モデル化できると
発見したとしか言えない。
言い換えれば、量子状態が
こう定義されるべき特別な理由があるからではなく、
それが機能するからこの定義を
選んでいる。
この量子状態の概念の数学に関しては、
それを理解して使いこなすための第一歩は
この定義を思い出すことだ。
ベクトルのユークリッドノルムの定義だ。
これは幾何学的にはベクトルの長さとして
考えられる。普通の方法で原点から始まる矢印として
紙に描いた場合の
2次元実ベクトルの長さについて
考えるのと同様だ。
具体的に言うと、こんな感じの列ベクトルvがあるとして、複素数の要素alpha 1からalpha nを持つと仮定する。
vのユークリッドノルムはここに示す通りに定義される。
これがユークリッドノルムの表記法で、話題にしているベクトルを二本線で挟む。
この場合はvで、ユークリッドノルムの定義は、和の平方根として定義される。
ベクトルの要素の絶対値の二乗の和だ。
つまり、量子状態ベクトルとは何かを別の言い方で定義すると、量子状態ベクトルとは複素数の要素を持つ列ベクトルで、
ユークリッドノルムが1に等しいもの、つまりユークリッドノルムに関して単位ベクトルだということだ。
なぜなら、絶対値の二乗の和が1に等しいのは、ユークリッドノルムが1に等しい場合にのみ成り立つからだ。
絶対値の二乗の和が1に等しい場合、平方根は何も変えない。
つまりそれが量子状態ベクトルだ。システムの古典的な状態に対応するインデックスを持つ列ベクトルで、
複素数の要素を持ち、ユークリッドノルムが1に等しい。
それが何を意味するのか、何を示唆するのか、この概念をどう解釈すべきかは別の問題で、ある意味では、
量子情報と計算の研究とは、この定義が何を示唆するかの探求だ。少なくとも情報処理という観点では。
これは単なる出発点に過ぎない。
ついでに言うと、ユークリッドノルム以外にもいわゆる「ノルム」が存在していて、この二本線の表記は
必ずしもユークリッドノルムを意味するとは限らない。
文脈によっては、この表記が別のノルムを指すこともある。
例えば、二乗も平方根もなしに絶対値の和を取るのは別のノルムで、
1ノルムと呼ばれることが多い。実はかなり多くの異なるノルムが存在する。
この表記が、どのノルムを指しているかの情報を提供する添字と一緒に使われることもある。
そうする場合、添字として数字の2を使うのがユークリッドノルムを意味するのが一般的だ。
ただし、このシリーズでは、このような列ベクトルがあれば、この二本線の表記だけで
ユークリッドノルムを意味する。
量子状態ベクトルの例をいくつか挙げよう。これらの特定の量子状態ベクトルはqubit状態ベクトルで、
つまりシステムの古典的な状態は0と1だ。
qubitという言葉は量子ビットの略で、量子状態になれるビットのことだ。
最初の2つの例はとても簡単だ。標準基底ベクトルのket 0とket 1は量子状態ベクトルだ。
どちらも列ベクトルで、インデックスは古典的な状態0と1に対応し、これらのベクトルの要素は複素数だ。
これらの特定のベクトルの要素は0と1で、実数であり実際には整数だが、複素数でもある。
たまたま虚部が0に等しいだけだ。
各ベクトルは1に等しい要素が一つ、0に等しい要素が一つある。
だから要素の絶対値の二乗を和すると、どちらの場合も1になる。
これらのベクトルが量子状態ベクトルであるための条件は満たされている。
次の2つの例は、プラス状態とマイナス状態と呼ばれる非常によく見かけるqubit状態だ。
画面に表示されているように、ket plusまたはket minusで表記され、ここに示す通りに定義される。
これらのベクトルの要素も複素数だ。今度は、正の1割る2の平方根または負の1割る2の平方根で、
絶対値の二乗の和を取ると、1/2足す1/2で1になる。
ちなみに、このようにketの中にプラス記号やマイナス記号を入れるのは少し奇妙に見えるかもしれない。なぜならこれらはシステムの古典的な状態ではないからだ。
しかしこの表記は使われており、すぐにこれに戻ってくる。
今のところ簡単に言えば、Dirac表記ではベクトルにどんな名前でもketの中に入れられる。
Dirac表記を使うとき、ベクトルは標準基底ベクトルでなくてもいい。
今のところ最後のqubit状態の例を挙げよう。
これは特別な名前を持たないqubitの量子状態ベクトルで、特に重要なわけでもない。
このベクトルの要素は、1足す2i割る3と、マイナス2/3だ。
これらは複素数で、この2つの要素の絶対値の二乗を計算すると、最初の要素は5/9になる。
2番目は4/9だ。だから絶対値の二乗の和は1に等しい。
そして最後の例だ。今度は古典的な状態が4枚のカードスートのシステムだ。
なぜ古典的な状態が4枚のカードスートのシステムが量子状態にあるのかはわからないが、原理的には可能で、
単なる例として示しているだけだ。
異なるスートに対応するエントリは、クラブが1/2、ダイヤが
マイナスiを2で割った値、
ハートは合計に現れないのでゼロ、スペードは2の平方根分の1だ。
これを列ベクトルとして表すとこうなる。古典状態を以前と同じ順序で並べると、
ここに見えるこの順序になる。
これらのエントリの絶対値の2乗を取ると、最初は1/4、次も1/4になる。
ゼロの絶対値の2乗はゼロに等しいので、そのエントリは
合計に寄与しない。
そして最後は1/2になる。つまり合計は1になり、このベクトルが
量子状態ベクトルであるための条件を満たす。
さて、少し前にket plusとket minusという表記を使って、
標準基底ベクトルではない2つのqubit状態ベクトルを指した。
この点に少し戻って、Dirac表記が標準基底ベクトルだけでなく
任意のベクトルにどう使われるかを説明したい。
すでに述べたように、braやketの内側にはどんな名前でも使って
ベクトルを参照できる。
ketは列ベクトルで、braは行ベクトル、以前と同じだ。
例えば、ギリシャ文字のpsiはketの内側で任意のベクトルを指すのに
よく使われる。
ここでは、特別な名前を持たない以前の状態ベクトルに
名前をつけるためにpsiを使っている。
こうする場合、ket psiはそれ自体では必ずしも
意味を持つわけではない。
単にベクトルの名前であり、列ベクトルであることを
明示するためにketの内側に置いているだけだ。
これは時々少し紛らわしくなることがあって、もしpsiという文字が
古典状態と関連付けられる可能性がある場合は曖昧さが生じる可能性がある。
例えばあるシステムの古典状態のような場合だが、通常は問題になることはなく、
このようにDirac表記を使わなくても構わない。
使いたくなければ使わなくていい。u、v、wのような小文字をketなしで使うのも
列ベクトルを表す良い方法だ。
より具体的には、量子状態ベクトルを表すのに使える。
どの表記を使って自分を表現するかは自分で選んでいい。
ただ、第一に、自分が表現しようとしていることの意味が
他者に明確に伝わることを確認する必要がある。
そして第二に、他者の表記の好みが自分と同じでなくても、
他者が表現しようとしていることを理解できることが必要だ。
任意のベクトルにDirac表記を使う上で非常に重要なルールが一つある。
例えばket psiとして書くことにした列ベクトルがある場合、
あるいはketの内側に別の名前があってもいいが、
行ベクトルであるbra psiは
ket psiの共役転置であると解釈される。
ここでは、この†（ダガー）が共役転置を指す等式として書かれている。
具体的には、第一にベクトルを転置する、つまりベクトルを横に倒して
列から行に変換する
エントリは変えずに。そして第二に、各エントリの複素共役を取る。
実は、転置とエントリごとの複素共役という2つの操作は
どちらの順序で行っても構わない、つまりこの2つの操作は可換だ。
この例のベクトルについては、このベクトルをket psiと呼ぶことにしたので、
bra psiはここにあるこのベクトルを意味すると理解される。
ket zeroとket oneをbra zeroとbra oneに変えることでベクトルを転置し、
各エントリの複素共役を取ったものだ。
だから1足す2iを3で割ったものがここで1引く2iを3で割ったものになっている。
これらのベクトルを列ベクトルと行ベクトルとして明示的に書くとこうなる。
ちなみに、このルールはbraとketの内側に古典状態がある場合に
使う表記と一致している。
その場合、エントリは1つを除いてすべてゼロなので、
複素共役を取っても何も変わらない。
量子状態がベクトルとして表現されることはわかったが、
量子状態にあるシステムで何ができるのか、
あるいはどう相互作用できるのかという意味や含意については
この時点ではまだ明らかではない。
これらの問題を明確にするために最初にやることは、
測定について議論することだ。
直感的に言えば、測定は量子系から古典情報を取り出すための
仕組みを提供する。
量子状態にあるシステムを観察しても、確率的状態が見えないのと同じように、
量子状態は見えない。
見えるのは古典状態であり、測定という概念がそのインターフェースを提供する。
私たち人間が量子系について何かを知りたければ、測定しなければならない。
そうすることで古典情報を取り出せる。
そのシステムがどんな量子状態にあったかについての古典情報をだ。
測定にはいくつかの異なる概念がある。違いは本質的に一般性の違いで、
最もシンプルで基本的なものから始めることにする。
それは一般的に標準基底測定と呼ばれるものだ。
これは後続のレッスンで一般化する。
いわゆる射影測定についてはレッスン3で話すし、その後シリーズの
第3ユニットで、
一般測定について話す。それは正作用素値測度、
略してPOVMとも呼ばれるものだ。
でも今は、標準基底測定に絞って考える。
システムに対して測定が
行われると、その測定の結果として起こりうる
古典的な結果の集合が存在する。
標準基底測定の場合、
起こりうる結果とは、測定対象のシステムの
古典的な状態そのものだ。
それらの古典的な状態はそれぞれある確率で測定の結果となるが、
その確率とは絶対値の二乗だ。
測定直前にシステムが
あった量子状態ベクトルの、
その古典的な状態に対応するエントリの絶対値の二乗だ。
複素数の絶対値の二乗は非負の実数だとわかっているし、
量子状態ベクトルの定義から
量子状態ベクトルのエントリの
絶対値の二乗の和は1に等しいとわかっている。
だからこれは理にかなっている。各古典的な状態はある確率で
測定の結果として現れ、確率の総和は1になる。
いくつか例を挙げよう。まず、
qubitがプラス状態にあるとしよう。
この qubit を標準基底測定で測定すると、
結果として0か
1が得られる。
0が得られる確率は、2の平方根分の1の
絶対値の二乗、つまり1/2で、
1が得られる確率も同じだ。
だからプラス状態を測定すると、一様なランダムビットが得られる。
システムがプラス状態ではなく
マイナス状態にある場合、測定は
全く同じように機能する。
確率は再び、起こりうる結果のそれぞれについて1/2だ。
唯一の違いはプラス記号がマイナス記号になることだが、
絶対値を取ると
何も変わらない。
この qubit 状態を測定すると、結果0が得られる確率は
3分の（1＋2i）の絶対値の二乗で、5/9だ。
結果1が得られる確率は
マイナス2/3の絶対値の二乗、つまり4/9だ。
最後に、標準基底状態、
ket zeroを測定すると確実に結果
zeroが得られるし、同様にket oneを測定すると
確実に結果oneが得られる。1の絶対値の二乗は1だからだ。
確率的な設定で見たものと同様に、これらの量子
状態、ket zeroとket oneを、システムが
それらの古典的な状態にある
こととして関連付けられる。
この例はその解釈と一致している。
さて、確率的な設定と同様に、
システムが量子状態にあるとき測定を行うと、
その測定を行った結果として、
一般的に状態が変化する。
特に、これも確率的な設定で見たものと
全く同じだ。
システムを測定して、測定の結果が
古典的な状態aであれば、
システムの新しい量子状態はket aになる。
だからここにあるこの状態について言えば、
確率的な設定で見たものと
同じ種類の振る舞いが見られる。
測定すると確率5/9で結果zeroが得られ、
その場合、状態は
ket zeroに遷移する。
確率4/9で
結果は1となり、状態はket oneに遷移する。
この現象は量子状態の崩壊と
呼ばれることがある。これは
量子力学の基礎を研究する人々が
夜も眠れないような類の話だ。
でも純粋に
数学的な観点からすれば、実にシンプルで、
確率的な場合と非常に類似している。
ここでの緊張の源は、ある意味、量子状態の基本的な
性質、それが何を表すか、
そして確率的な状態とどう違うか
に関わる。でも数学的なレベルでは、これはおそらく予想通りのことだ。
ちなみに、2回目の測定をすると、
最初の測定と全く
同じ結果が得られることに注目してほしい。
だから量子状態から取り出せる
古典的情報の量には限りがある。この点には近いうちに戻ってくる。
別のレッスンで。量子状態と測定、特に標準基底測定について話してきた。
標準基底測定は量子状態から
古典的情報を取り出す方法を提供する。
このレッスンの残りのトピックは
演算、特にユニタリ演算だ。これは量子状態が
どのように変化するかを記述する。当然、
量子状態ベクトルが確率ベクトルと異なる以上、
許容される演算の集合も
量子状態と古典的情報では異なると予想されるだろうし、
実際そのとおりだ。
確率的な状態への演算が確率的行列で表されるのに対して、
量子状態ベクトルへの演算は
ユニタリ行列で表される。
ユニタリ行列の定義を示そう。
複素数を成分とする正方行列Uは、
ここに見える等式を満たすならば
ユニタリだ。
ダガーは共役転置を表していて、これはDirac記法の話をした少し前にベクトルに対してすでに見たやつだ。
ここではベクトルではなく行列に対して共役転置を行っているが、本質的には同じことだ。
行列を転置するというのは、行と列を入れ替えることを意味していて、JKの要素がKJの要素になる。
さらに、各要素の複素共役も取る。
また、ここにあるこの表記は単位行列を意味している。
ここにある二つの等式は実は等価だ。片方があれば、もう片方も自動的に成り立つ。
どちらもUが可逆であり、逆行列が共役転置に等しいということと等価だ。
ちなみに、これは正方行列の場合にのみ成り立つ。正方行列でない行列の場合、二つの等式のどちらか一方は成り立つかもしれないが、
もう一方は成り立たない。
でもここでは、正方行列について話している。
これがユニタリ行列の標準的な定義で、行列がユニタリかどうかを確認しやすいのが嬉しいところだ。
両側から行列にその共役転置を掛けて、単位行列が得られるかどうかを確認するだけだ。
ユニタリ行列を特徴づける等価な方法がもう一つあって、それは正方行列Uが、掛け算をしたときにユークリッドノルムを
決して変えない場合にのみユニタリだということだ。N×N行列Uがユニタリであることは、Uとvの積のユークリッドノルムが
複素数の要素を持つすべてのn次元列ベクトルvに対してvのユークリッドノルムに等しいことと同値だ。
したがって、vが量子状態ベクトルなら、U×vも量子状態ベクトルになる。なぜなら量子状態ベクトルは
ユークリッドノルムが1に等しいベクトルに他ならないからだ。
実はもう少し言えることがあって、ユニタリ行列というのはまさに量子状態ベクトルを常に
量子状態ベクトルに変換する行列だ。これは確率的行列と確率ベクトルで見られる状況に似ている。
確率的行列はまさに確率ベクトルを常に確率ベクトルに変換する行列だ。
つまり、演算を行列で表現すると決めた時点で、それは変換が状態を表すベクトルに線形に作用するということと同じだが、
許容される演算の集合に対するこれらの選択は、少なくとも数学的な意味では自然に導かれる。
では、qubitのユニタリ演算の例をいくつか見てみよう。
ユニタリ演算のさらに多くの例は後続のレッスンで見ることになる。二つ以上の古典的な状態を持つシステムにおけるユニタリ演算も含めて。
でも今は、qubitのユニタリ演算だけに集中しよう。
これらの特定の例は何度も繰り返し出てくるので、これらの演算をしっかり理解しておく価値は確実にある。
最初の例のコレクションは、いわゆるPauli演算だ。
これらはPauli行列に対応する演算で、ここに示されている。
これらはすべてユニタリで、前の定義に従って各々について確認できる。
これらの特定の行列は自分自身の共役転置に等しく、つまりすべてHermitian行列だ。
したがって、この場合にそれらがすべてユニタリであることを確認するのは、各々を二乗して結果が単位行列になることを確認するだけだ。
これらの行列に対して見られる名前はかなり標準的で、シグマx、シグマy、シグマzは単純にX、Y、Zとも呼ばれる。
ただし、大文字のX、Y、Zは量子情報の文脈でさえも他の目的で一般的に使われることがあるので注意が必要だ。
でも、これらの行列の非常に一般的な名前ではある。
シグマxまたはX演算は、ビットフリップまたはNOT演算とも呼ばれ、古典的な文脈ですでに見たものだ。
そしてシグマzまたはZ演算は位相フリップとも呼ばれる。
ここで、標準基底ベクトルに対するこれらの演算の作用が見られ、これらの名前がどこから来るのかがある程度説明できる。
ここに示されている作用に基づいて、シグマxをビットフリップと呼ぶのは確かに理にかなっている。
単純に0から1、または1から0へとビットを反転させる。
ここに示されている作用に基づいて、シグマzを位相フリップと呼ぶのも理にかなっている。
でも今の時点でそれが明確でないとしても、それで構わない。
この演算は何度も繰り返し出てくるし、ket oneの基底ベクトルの前にマイナス符号を付けてket zeroには付けない意義も
それが位相フリップと呼ばれる理由も、後でより明確になるだろう。
次の例はHadamard演算で、ここに示されているこの行列で表される。ほぼ常にHという名前が付けられている。
HがユニタリであることをチェックするのはもちろんHermitian行列の場合と同様の計算だが、私が邪魔をしなければここで確認できる。
Pauli行列と同様に、HはHと自分自身の共役転置が一致する。
つまりここに示されているこの等式が成り立って、掛け算を実行すると必要とされているように単位行列が得られる。
3番目の例は
実際には位相演算として知られる
ユニタリ演算のクラス全体だ。
これらの演算は、
thetaが任意の実数であるとき、
ここで見えているこの形を取る
任意の行列で表される。
つまり、ここのこの成分は
常に単位円上の複素数になる。
このような行列は常にユニタリだ。それは自分で確認してほしい。
この場合、共役転置は
ここのこの数が1または-1にならない限り、
元の行列とは等しくならない。
その場合、
単位行列かsigma zのどちらかになる。
これらはすでに見てきた。
具体的には、転置は
この行列に何もしないが、
各成分の複素共役を取ると
ここのこの成分が
e^に変わる。
ここにあるこれら2つの特定の演算は、
位相演算の特に重要な例だ。
最初のものは、
thetaをpi/2とすると、
ここのこの行列が得られる。
これは一般にS演算、あるいは
circuit の話をするときにはS gateと呼ばれる。
このレッスンでは扱わないが、
それは近いうちに
扱う重要なトピックだ。
2番目はこの演算だ。T演算、またはT gateと呼ばれる。
これについては、
thetaはpi/4に等しい。
だから指数関数を計算すると、
ここのこの値が得られる。
これはi√2分の(1+i)だ。
これらの演算のいくつかが
実際に動く様子を確認するための
簡単な例をいくつか示そう。
Hadamard演算の
ket zeroとket oneへの作用がここにある。
行列とベクトルの積を計算すると、
それぞれプラス状態と
マイナス状態が得られることがわかる。
一方、プラス状態とマイナス状態に
Hadamard演算を適用すると、
ket zeroとket oneに戻る。
少し整理すると、作用がより明確にわかる。
Hadamard演算は
zero状態とプラス状態の間、
そしてone状態とマイナス状態の間を
行き来する変換を行う。
ここにあるこれら2つの式について、
これがプラス状態とマイナス状態の違いを
検出する簡単な方法を与えることに注目してほしい。
このレッスンの前半で見たように、
標準基底測定に対して
プラス状態とマイナス状態を測定すると、
どちらの場合も一様ランダムビットが得られるが、
それでは違いを検出するのに役立たない。
しかし、Hadamard演算を適用してから
測定すれば、元の状態がプラス状態だった場合は
zeroが見える。
そして元の状態がマイナス状態だった場合は
oneが見える。
つまり、これら2つの状態は確かに異なっており、
今説明した方法で
完全に識別できる。
その方法とは、最初に
Hadamard演算を適用してから測定するというものだ。
以前見た特に特殊でない
qubit状態の例に戻ると、
Hadamard演算がその状態に
何をするかがわかる。
ここに見える形式に変換して
積を計算することで。
そしてここに結果がある。
望むなら、これをDirac記法に戻せる。
これがこのような作用を計算する
一つの方法だ。
もう一つの例がある。これは、
行列ベクトル形式に明示的に変換しなくても
いい場合があることを示している。
Dirac記法を直接使って
これらの計算を行うこともできる。
この例はT演算に関するもので、
参照用にここに示す。
この演算は標準基底状態に対して
ここに示す作用を持つ。
例えば、T演算のプラス状態への作用を
計算したい場合、
プラス状態の定義を展開することから始められる。
そして線形性を使って
ここに示すように結果を表せる。
ここで上にあるこれらの式を代入して、
2番目の項を少し簡略化すれば
結果が得られる。
何らかの理由で結果に
Hadamard演算を適用したい場合は、
同様のことができる。
まず、T演算がプラス状態に作用する式を代入して、
前と同じように線形性を使う。
次に、ket zeroとket oneに作用する
Hadamard演算についてすでに持っている式を代入すると、
これが得られる。そして、プラス状態と
マイナス状態を展開すると
ここに示すこの式が得られる。
足し算だけで簡略化でき、最終結果はこれだ。
この例は特に特殊なものではない。
ただ、この代替的だが同等の
計算方法を示すためのものだ。
これらの演算の作用の計算には、
状況に応じてどちらの方法でも
より便利な方を使えばいい。
ユニタリ演算についての最後の点として、
ユニタリ演算の合成は
行列の積で表されることを述べておく。
確率的な設定と同様に、
つまり、ユニタリ演算の列の作用は
計算できる。
行列を掛け合わせるだけで。
そうすると、結合された作用を表す
単一のユニタリ行列が得られる。
演算の列の作用を表す。
確率的行列のときと同様に、
ユニタリ行列は積について閉じているので、
常にユニタリ行列が得られる。
ユニタリ演算を合成したとき。
行列を正しい順序で
掛けることを確認しないといけない。
しかし、確率的演算のときと同じで、
最初に適用する演算の行列は
常に行列積の右辺に現れ、
最後のものが左辺に現れる。
前と同様に、順序は逆になっている。
つまり、左から右ではなく右から左へと
合成する。
ここに、not演算の平方根として知られる演算が
生じる興味深い例がある。
Hadamard演算を適用し、続いてS演算を、
そしてもう一つのHadamard演算を適用すると
仮定しよう。
これら3つの演算の結合された作用は
この積で記述される。
これが最初のHadamard演算、これがS演算、
そしてこれが2番目のHadamard演算だ。
行列の積を計算すると——ここでは明示的に示さないが、
望むなら自分でできる——
結果はここにあるこの行列だ。ユニタリ行列であり、
直接確認することもできるし、
あるいはユニタリ行列が
積について閉じているという事実を信頼してもいい。
これら3つの行列はユニタリなので、
それは必ずユニタリになる。
すでに見てきたとおりだ。
ここでは特定の
量子状態ベクトルは念頭にない。
任意の量子状態ベクトルに対して
この演算の列を適用することを想像でき、
この行列がその作用を記述する。
この結合された演算、つまりここにあるこの行列で
記述されるものが、
not演算の平方根と呼ばれる理由は、
2回適用することで
not演算、すなわちsigma xまたはX演算が
得られるからだ。
この演算を2回適用することは、
行列を2乗する、つまり
自身に掛けることで表される。
それを計算すると、結果が
Pauli x行列であることがわかる。
それはちょっと奇妙で、
古典的な情報ではできないような
面白いことが量子情報でできる
というヒントを与えてくれる。
古典的な演算、つまり確率的行列で
表されるものの中に、
2回適用するとnot演算になるものはない。
これは、量子演算が古典的演算と
まったく異なる振る舞いをすることを示す
良い例だ。
以上でレッスン1は終わりだ。このレッスンでは、
孤立した単一システムにおける
量子情報の仕組みについて議論した。
次のレッスンでは、
複数のシステムにおける
量子情報の仕組みについて話す。
ご視聴ありがとう。質問があれば、
下のコメント欄に
遠慮なく書いてほしい。